if you would ask me like a year ago what
are you going to do so I'm going to
change life of people but you are saying
it and you're not feeling it now like
every step that we're doing every client
that we're helping you can really feel
and like real understanding like that
we're really Changing Life of people and
it's a process to understand
how much impact you can make welcome to
20 minute leaders just sit back relax
and learn from the leaders of today it's
a journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside FM Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with ctek
[Music]
[Applause]
well let's get right into it so tell me
first a little bit about yourself and
your journey leading up to the the
founding of 65 you know how did this
whole thing come about
sure and so it's actually an interesting
story a I learned a lot I really didn't
didn't want and still don't want to be a
lawyer never actually practice in any
way uh but one of the only good things
above good friends from the University
was that I practiced in kind of like a
legal clinic really trying to help it
was like about seniors uh trying to help
them in the retirement years with
understanding that their asset is their
home and actually you're sitting every
week for several hours talking seniors
about their financial life about the
struggling that they're facing mostly
financially struggling and you
understand that
a story that is coming over and over is
the fact that lots of them they have a
house that they own they want to
continue to live in their home
and they don't have enough money
to fund their kind of like monthly
expenses there is like kind of like a
constant gap between their income and
expenses and like down the road Zone
like seven years ago I told myself
listen tally you're going to change it I
don't I didn't know yet then how and
when and what's going to do how we're
going to make it happen but it was like
really clear to me that we need to do
something there
and so what you know what what really
led to that sort of realization
um from an intellectual perspective and
then from an emotional perspective why
did this catch you so so concretely
it's a great question and to be honest I
don't have the answer like one of the
things that I'm thinking a lot about it
that
in some way most of the entrepreneurs I
think are trying to solve problems that
they're facing on their ongoing life
they're trying to fix their life
um and I don't know why retirement
and is sitting on me I will tell that
them I'm super happy that I'm there
because I think that overall there is
like a huge lack of innovation when
we're thinking about seniors about
things that are not in like that
regular entrepreneur mindset
is it and so
what was the really the sort of the
founding Journey you've identified the
problem you've identified the pain point
that the fact that you want
yeah so so it was like a bit more
complicated like every real story uh
started when my partner ayal and I we
decided that we want to do something
together and we took an office in Tel
Aviv
with nothing really nothing above the
fact that we're paying rent to an office
and we're going to be there 20 hours a
day and and we started there trying to
think what we can build together uh
really quickly like run or my amazing
partner in our city or join us to this
journey and and we put on the table like
few problems that we can solve and I
told them listen
it this problem it's a huge problem like
home equity and retirement it's a huge
problem it's going to be one of the most
challenging Journeys that we can do
together
but we can really change life real life
we can change light with people and
let's make it happen and and that's how
we started
um
kind of like from a funding perspective
so officially we started in May 22 we
raised kind of like a press seed
uh try to bring money on from kind of
like add value investors so late finting
entrepreneurs like shy winninger from
Lemonade mapanbar familio Ron from
empathy uh people that are really coming
with add value or people from the
retirement industry and other and like
three months ago we raised money also
from like to micro VCS both of them are
sitting in the valley and one of them
also is sitting here in Israel
something phenomenal okay so so walk me
through you know those early stages of
of really honing in on the problem and
coming up with with your home income as
a solution
so we started with the fact that in some
way
everybody understand not everybody at
least that but we understand that there
is a lot of seniors a lot of American
seniors to be more accurate and that are
getting into their retirement years they
don't have enough liquid savings the
regular American savings account 401K
High array they don't have enough money
there and the fact that with the fact
that they don't have enough money there
is like raising cost of living and this
combination it is it's difficult and on
the other side they most of them live in
a house that they own like if we're
we're looking on the Baby Boomers like
the Baby Boomers generation and 80 of
them live in a house that they own so
it's very so it's a very interesting
problem and and we try to understand
what are the traditional that the market
can offer to those seniors today and the
most known
a solution today is the reverse mortgage
that started like almost like a century
ago
and in very short is not
trying it all in some way to serve the
needs of those seniors like they're not
they're trying to think like let's sell
them onion and and don't talk with the
client forever and we tried it from like
scratch to let's try to understand what
those seniors needs and then how we can
build the financial product from scratch
in a way that will serve the needs of
those clients in the best way in the
understanding of this if we will build
the best product
we can win the market
is it okay got it so
then what happens
then from like from like the funding
perspective
well from you know from from building
the product and starting to get it to
Market and really validating it and
seeing how how you're gonna solve it
and um so we started with like really
creating from scratch like a financial
product it's a long process that
includes a lot of like legal work
because we created here like a very
unique little structure so it was like
long month in a huge amount of money to
build a legal structure that can we can
offer it under it dates
uh building like the full financial
model a technology that can support us
and of course from like the distribution
Channel also work to understand how we
can approach those seniors and in some
way convince them that
we're going to take their house in some
way and they can trust us and that was
like also like a long journey to
understand how we are going to
distribute the product how we're going
to to talk with seniors
um
we figure out like
kind of like a very quickly that we're
not going to do only like a paid media
regular
ads because it's not like it's not this
kind of product and and we started to
work with kind of like Financial
professionals so financial advisor
people from the mortgage industry people
that are
trustable in some way and understand how
seniors are thinking about products and
we started to collaborate with with
those kind of like
guys that are helping us now to to
promote the product in front of their
clients uh when like from like the
journey perspective again we launched
the product by the end of November like
exactly two months ago we're operating
today only in Florida and we have now
like few dozens of clients that were
actually changing their life and we have
a huge list like more than what we
expected we have like around like 500
clients that passed like the full
application process share with us every
information that we asked for including
like kind of like sensitive information
like their social security and because
we are a young inference startup we have
like a limited capacity so we cannot on
board them but it is amazing to
understand like
how people are responding to the product
that you thought about it in a small
office in Tel Aviv and now you have
people all over Florida that are that
are that want your products and
in some way more interesting is a
why people want your product because we
had few reasons like why we think those
seniors will be interested in the
product
and one of the interesting things that
you're actually in the market people are
coming to you with crazy ideas like how
they can use your product in their life
then and it's it's really inspired
I I love it so going back to sort of the
origination of this and the fact that
it's a little bit different from from a
pain that you may experience but you're
solving a pain that many others
experience how do you get into the
headspace of retired individuals to even
know not even just from a financial
product perspective but from a
communication and from a delivery
perspective how do you get into the the
mind of of these retirees
so a great question
and I will say that it's not like a
silver bullet it's not like you made
something and it's all set up it's a
journey and we're doing like we started
of course with talking with clients
about their life about what they're
looking for about what's the reason that
they're not sleeping at night uh and how
and and then you you can figure out like
how you can help them there's like the
Great Book like it ask your mom or
something like that like how to
interview like clients so that's like it
was interesting talking also to kind of
like Financial professional family
members uh to understand how we can help
uh their family their clients and how we
can support them in their financial life
and then we are launching the product
we're showing some demos and we can say
like responses how they're actually
responding to to the product so it's
like
it's a long process and we still have
lots to learn about how to make it
better and we're always working about
educational materials and then changing
girl and land which in a just play
things in the product to really make it
in the best way that we can make it
happen
Sith incredible and so let's talk a
little bit about building trust in this
product when you go over your website I
think it's one of the something that's
the thing that keeps popping up is the
trust that you're creating and and you
also mentioned before the trust that you
need to create for these people to to to
give you something that is that is so
valuable and especially to a young
startup so how do you build what have
you found helpful in in building this
trust with them
so I will take your question even like
to the next stage and I will tell you
that the biggest challenge that 65 is
facing
is the fact that we need to build here
like a very trustable company because
we're talking with seniors about their
houses about retirement about income and
like the most super heavy topics in the
world that that's the thing that we're
discussing and we want to make it into a
digital process
super simple like
in some way the the Simplicity of the
process is one of the challenging Parts
because when you're thinking in the
tradition world like a process should
take you three months you're going to
pay five thousand dollars you're going
to do a ton of paperwork and we're
offering them the process that will take
them only 20 minutes so so really
building a trust here that's like the
the biggest part here
and and to continue my my previous
answer it's a journey it's not like you
you don't build the trust it's it's a
process of building we're starting with
the fact that for example we're not
doing direct to Consumer we're not
relying on the directive consumer we are
working with trustable entities in some
way in the senior community we're
working with financial advisors that are
offering our product to their clients
and they know their clients for like a
decade eight or two or three or more
than that so so we are one of the main
reasons we're working with partners with
kind of like a B2B to see and
distribution way is the fact that we we
that's one of the ways that we are
bridging on this Gap trust in some way
and so that's the biggest thing we have
we're doing today we are working
to build a huge in one of the
interesting and unique things about
seniors that they love to read like me
you in overall the Young Generation if
it's more than
two sentences ah I personally am losing
it and when we're coming to seniors we
understand that we need to build we need
to to offer the materials to read and in
our application process we're sending
them we're giving them access to
materials that explains them about the
product about how the product can served
about how legally this product is
structured and we're working also with
Blake one of the most recognized uh
financial planners in the state her name
is Margarita Chan she's like one of the
she's like the top 10 financial planners
in the states by mrpedian like the last
like five or six years so we are working
with her closely to build our kind of
like education center to those singers
and we're ordering here every day how to
make it better how to make the process
better how to approach the seniors in a
better way but it is a journey
yeah no no I I'm sure tell me a little
bit about the vision so growing from
here over the next couple of years what
are you what are you looking for in 65
what's going to happen
so 65 is a retirement income company
and one of the things that we understand
that when you are getting to retirement
you have lots of assets you have
liquid assets like your 401k and Social
Security and Ira and whatever what you
have and you have more lockdown and it's
it's it's a huge Market but overall
you're getting in retirement and you
have grown
it's hard to get income in retirement
even if you have the money in our big
vision and we will make it happen then
in a few years from now is is to take
all of your savings and to connect it
into the 65 card and like that so the 65
card should faciliate like it it's like
a One-Stop shop in some way for your
income in retirement years we are
starting with home equity because home
equity is the overall biggest single
asset and the most blocked ones so in in
the home equity it's like that's that's
the the biggest pain points
but it's a pain point in in a broader
way and that's what we want to take like
my vision is that I will take you in two
years from now to any Walmart shop in
the states and every second the American
Senior will buy his groceries with a 65
card
because it's it's a better way to to
retire
yeah and I think that
um you know stepping back to the initial
initial initial conversation we've had
right at the beginning of sort of the
why
I think it ties nicely to the to the
vision you just articulated in and I
also want to finish on the why and so if
we're looking today as to you know why
you're waking up every day and this is
what you're doing has your why evolved
at all from when you first started out
the company have you discovered some
things that that changed your why or now
that you have 10 people on your team and
you know why do you do why every day do
you go on this journey again
so the why is the same but in some way
you understand the why better like
everybody like if you will ask if you
would ask me like a year ago what are
you going to do so I'm going to change
life of people but
you're saying it and you're not feeling
it now like every step that we're doing
every client that we're helping
you can really feel and like real
understanding like that we're really
Changing Life of people and
[Music]
it's a process to understand
how much impact you can make and that's
like the wire it's just the Y is just
getting deeper in some way
doesn't change
I love it I think that's just a really
really cool and Kelly I really want to
thank you for for coming here and for
sharing with me your journey and that of
65 and I'm wishing you best of luck and
wishing you to make a whole lot of
impact on a lot of retirees and and I
think that the whole trust component
here from a product perspective is
fascinating and so I'm looking forward
to following from the side and learning
so thank you very very much and best of
luck with 65. thank you it was a great
pleasure to talk with you and want to be
in touch
thank you
easy